Okay, so what I've done here Michael, is I have
drawn both of these lines. So here's the line 15 p
minus 5. This is a case when b is a
resigner. This is my best attempt at drawing it to scale.
You start out minus 5, as you point out, and
you end up with plus 10. And this is the line
where b is a seer. That's minus ten b plus 5,
so you start out with plus 5. And you end at
minus 5. Okay?
>> Cool.
>> So, what do you notice about these two lines?
>> They make an x? So they intersect.
>> They do intersect. Can you tell where they intersect?
>> How would I solve that?
>> You'd have a quiz. Okay Michael, so here's a quiz. Where
do the two lines intersect? Think you know how to figure it out?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. Then go.